un régimen de excepción en el salvador
por 30 días es el decreto que fue
aprobado este domingo por el congreso
limita la libertad de reunión y permite
los arrestos sin órdenes judiciales
entre otras cosas el presidente nadie
buque le pidió la medida en un contexto
de aumento de homicidios por parte de
las pandillas con 76 asesinatos en las
últimas 48 horas por mí está bueno que
han aprobado porque fíjese que ha
demasiado este violencia usted
muchas de ellas pues están causando
mayores se había calmado esto permanece
eso ya por revancha está contra el
gobierno
cometer homicidios permite las bandas
criminales afianzar su poder y les sirve
de mecanismo de negociación con el
gobierno hay una fuerte sospecha e
indicios muy muy fuertes también de una
posible negociación entre el gobierno y
las pandillas y esto puede ser quizá uno
de los orígenes de este incremento una
muestra de fuerza por parte de las
pandillas y una respuesta también del
gobierno ante esa demostración en un
estado ya considerado como altamente
autoritario el régimen de excepción
podría llevar a abusos y más control de
la población hay reportes ya de gente
que se le ha impedido salir de su casa
para poder hacer sus actividades
cotidianas y esto no es parte de la
aplicación del régimen que se aprobó en
la madrugada y por tanto es muy probable
que con instituciones altamente
represivas como la policía
los militares
tengamos un alza de abusos policiales y
militares en estos 10 hacia cerca de un
año busquen les destituyó de los jueces
de la corte suprema para imponer a
magistrados afines a sus intereses lo
que llevó a que varias organizaciones de
derechos humanos denunciarán el desvío
autoritario